how's life out there in uh new york city
my man
sucks is it bad i've been i heard it's
better than uh la though
oh my god it's like bad too when i was
out in l.a that was worse actually when
i was there but that was before they
canceled indoor dining
yeah surprised i guess i'm just
surprised to hear that
which leads us to you launching this
whole kind of fundraiser help
out these small businesses
how'd this idea come about we did a
little background on it but i want to
hear it from the horse's mouth
yeah so you know i was ranting raven
which i tended to do
uh and it was actually i was at the pool
in miami it was when
indoor dining got shut down in new york
and i went out and made like an
instagram video
basically just saying i don't understand
what they expect these small businesses
specifically restaurants bars to do
because they're already on their last
legs and now you're not letting them do
indoor dining it's the middle of winter
in new york
so what's going to happen you got to do
one thing you let them
open up and serve or you got to give
them a lot of money
from the government or else they're just
going to go out of business so that was
the gist of the rant
um and then i got challenged basically
it's like
this guy marcus lemonis was like hey big
mouth put your money where your mouth
is if you're gonna talk about it so
that's what we did so i donated 500
grand
to what we call the bar stool fund and
we said hey if you're a small business
owner
and you need help contact us and then we
basically solicited donations from our
readers i twitter shane some of my
friends who are
wealthy and we've raised about 18
million 18
five in about i don't know 12 days or
something how do you get
all these submissions and we record the
videos
yeah of us telling them and it's kind of
taking on a life of its own
and how do you vet the small businesses
that get it because i'm sure there's
some shysters out there
yeah you know it so here's the process
we get emails
and there's two requirements one you
gotta prove you're running a successful
business
before the pandemic and then we assume
you can go back to it after
and your payroll has to be on still
paying employees so those are the two
things we look for
and then we get emails with the stories
videos we have a team led by
this uh woman liz gonzalez who goes
through it it escalates up to me
we talk to the people would you tell
would i be shocked in the span of doing
i think we've done 75 businesses or
something so far
that one or two slipped through
it could happen but i mean our finance
team follows up ask for all the
paperwork
tax rent everything like that
but there's no charity in the history of
charities i don't think
that hasn't been you know stolen from or
whatever i agree i'll take those odds
does it surprise you that the media is
not covering this because this is
probably the most successful
effort to help small businesses during
the whole pandemic
and it just seems like the media should
be reporting on this all the time
and it doesn't seem like that's the case
does that surprise you yeah they don't
give a [ __ ] yeah they seem to not give a
[ __ ]
is that or is there more of them caring
than i've seen i haven't seen
i've seen like fox you went on fox but i
feel like this is all this does is help
small business owners so you you know
these this is the people that these
people
pretend or should care about i feel like
they should report on this all the time
yeah so fox has covered it and covered
it a decent amount
um and then the local like affiliates of
abc or fox like if we
if a small business is in you know
arkansas the local station will do it
the national besides fox there's been
very little
um and it's stupid like i i did
tweet something out cnn like had a tweet
that beyonce had donated
like i think it was 500 grants
at yeah a hundred five thousand dollar
grants
so it came out to half a million dollars
basically which is great
and it should everything should get
publicity they haven't mentioned it once
and to me sometimes i think rightly or
wrongly people think i'm political i
always say i don't really think i am i
hate the far left i hate the far right
but in this case it doesn't like we're
helping
all sorts of business i don't know what
their politics it just the more
publicity we get
the louder we can bang the drum the more
donations come in
the more people we can help and we're
never going to have enough money to help
all the businesses
we're getting 10 000 emails so to me yes
if you
care about small business at all you
should publicize it it can only help
do you do you believe in the uh
conspiracy that they're trying to get
rid of uh
you know those small businesses that's
that's the government's agenda
a lot of people say that and maybe i'm
naive but
i can't belie that that is such a
preposterous thing that like i don't
believe like the vaccine is putting like
chips in people you know
i can't get my head there to think
there's somebody
who would want to put out a business
that has been passed down
generations for like 50 years like that
person
if that's true you should be executed i
think it makes more sense that they're
just idiots and they're
they're enforcing this uh shut down a
very sloppy and uneven way and it's
hurting a lot of people
correct i think there's no grand design
i don't think there's a grand
conspiracy or a plan i think these
people they're just idiots and they're
out of touch i don't think they have any
clue
how affected people really are are like
egotistical selfish self-absorbed people
in general
right and like there's so many side
agendas
and so much self-interest and that's the
problem and that's why something like
we get the money we get it in that's all
we care about so politics sucks i mean
that's i don't think that's
a news flash and all they care about
is themselves staying in power and
that's it
yep who do you who's mayor you think is
worse ours here with uh
newsome or you think that l.a guy kind
of the new york guy sucks
you know they've both done things that
i don't know how they can look
themselves in the mirror to a degree
like when newsome's like you can't go
out and he goes to french laundry it's
like right
what the [ __ ] are you doing and that's
not again political that's like
what an [ __ ] right is writing books
about
how [ __ ] terrifically he handled this
pandemic in the middle of the
pandemic when the city's locked down
like what are you doing
he just won an emmy he won an emmy he
wanted me for killing
how about refuse the emmy yeah
like and by the way we we're a small
company and we've pivoted to doing this
but if you have the money don't have the
money for small business
like the government could set up a
charity and get a ton of not charity but
like a foundation people donate
put a ton of people going through it
effectively to find out who's eligible
like how do you not think of that right
i i don't think people would trust the
government if they
said they were going to do that i think
that's why yours is so successful
because people know where that money's
going to go i think people trust
you guys will do a lot better of a job
finding actually worthy businesses
yeah i mean there's a lot out there and
it's
so the first time we did it that like
the first
company and beside one of them basically
the the person liz who goes through the
email she's like this person's singled
out that they really like barcelona
they're a fan of yours
it'd be really cool if you just called
and delivered the news
so i did and i facetimed and and they
broke down
and i wasn't recording it but it was
pretty obvious
like okay i gotta record this because it
it was like
very visceral the reaction yeah and
that's what is moving the donations
these videos
is pretty you know i'm not the most like
sensitive guy
but if you watch the videos it's hard
not to be like okay i want to donate to
this
because you can see the weight being
like lifted they're breaking down
yeah so it is have you decided to help
any larger businesses like chipotle or
starbucks or anything
chase manhattan i mean they need help
too i mean everybody's suffering right
ruth chris everybody nike
yeah no no none of those have received
help
you uh i was just in i was in florida
last week on tour you were in miami last
week
i don't know how bad it is in new york
but it was weird seeing uh how florida
they're just a different breed man like
they were eating in restaurants
they were you know i was getting yelled
at because i had a mask on it was
strange
so i've been in miami for every like big
event recently like super bowl art basel
you name it i've been there it was never
busier than it was this week agree
i mean it was because everyone's leaving
everywhere else so it's like
get me out of new york get me out of la
there's people from all over there i
mean it was madness do you think
something happens after this pandemic
where new york and la aren't the center
of the universes anymore and do you see
other cities
in the country kind of becoming more
interesting and especially if they raise
taxes you think
uh you know there's more of an
entrepreneurial culture it might be in a
place like
austin or nashville or florida yes
like i i do and and i don't know if
that's the goal to a
degree yeah insane i think there's a
real chance
that you know a miami and and the mayor
there
certainly realizes it is wildly
aggressive trying to get companies to go
there
all you hear everyone going to austin um
nashville yeah
david level it's like it seems like a
new york
or an la doesn't want business right
yeah it's very strange and they don't
they don't care when people leave when
these huge businesses leave they don't
they're complacent they've been too big
for too long and i don't think they
you know it's like you know somebody
that's been making money for so long
they forgot
like the you know the ingredients that
made them successful yeah dave have you
thought about leaving new york at all
because in l.a it's a [ __ ] storm like
all our friends left me and tim are the
only ones
yeah we're it that's him yeah no i i so
i'm going back to miami today and i'm
debating getting a place there
but would you would you move the whole
bar stool operation down there
taxes would but i if enough people here
are like yeah we're behind it
me personally i do in two seconds but
i'm not gonna make like everybody
relocate out there
but if people like yeah let's i'm down
for it i mean the tax difference
i have people every single day now that
i've become a little more successful
with barcelona who are like you're an
idiot
like the tax you're getting murdered in
taxes for what
it's like it's so much cheaper in
florida and the weather and the girls
and everything else fair point
yeah it's just better well great that's
a great [ __ ] thing you're doing and i
i wish that um what could people do if
they want to
give you money so everything is at
barcelon.com that's both
if you're a struggling business you can
submit an application we look for a
video tell your story
and there's a form give us all the info
and if you want donate
it's there as well and the thing that i
just keep stressing
we've raised a lot relatively speaking
but it's really a little for the need
so every dollar matters and the beauty i
think of what we're doing and why we're
doing it
we get the money and we get it out like
the sec within 72 hours of us
contacting the business the money is in
their account that's cool we're not
going away after one month
we're there until the pandemic's done
because what's the point of giving
somebody money
and then three months later they're in
the same spot so it is a good cause
we're doing the best we can um and we're
helping a lot of people you're doing the
lord's work well what we're gonna i
don't know if this even
helps at all we're gonna donate five
thousand dollars from king of the sting
to the donation of course it helps
everything helps i appreciate it i'm
gonna
i'm gonna apply for the thousand that
you donated so i hope that even
i will see what happens traveling
podcast needs money yes yes
have there uh have have any celebrities
kind of
have have any celebrities jumped on
board and uh got behind this movement
yeah dana white did a hundred grand
it took him one second we called him out
because i know him he's like yeah
i think i could have named a million
that he would have done it he did it so
fast
tom brady did it edelman did it um
kid rock unsolicited called me out of
the blue
donated 100 grand i was on the phone
with sylvester stallone
yesterday um so a lot are coming forward
i want elon musk
who i bet you'll want to do it right
yeah infinity money is right up his
alley he just sold all his cribs in uh
beverly hills he had like three of them
all next door he sold all of them now
he's in texas
yeah i tweeted at him but i don't know
him personally
right um i don't need do you know elon i
don't know elon
at all i mean i know i mean i know you
know anyone who's
feel free to get him everyone's hitting
me up it seems like right up his alley
feel free to have him give it a shout
out seems like something he'd be behind
too yeah
that's a good point yeah we'll we'll try
yeah i'll try
elon i can't make any promises but i'll
text rogan for you
yeah all right well that's good enough
yeah
how have you been able to do your uh
your pizza
uh previews show oh yeah that that never
ends i
though those are daily still going
you've had no problem finding spots and
[ __ ]
no because you you can still get the
pizza there now
i'm jealous of that man because because
i do a food show but
it's not just me i have to have guests
on because if coveted it's been a
nightmare have you
have you buried the hatchet with bryce
hall i know that you guys were in uh
he's the softest human of all time
he's a i've never seen a guy with
thinner skin in my life he's got a hot
you you had a great point you go you got
a hot girlfriend you got all the money
you just enjoy life
right yeah a girl said we said he looked
like sid from ice age he's acting like
we called him hitler it makes no sense
yeah yeah it's young kids but it's funny
that's a funny podcast he does
with uh he does a podcast with like a
young dave does yeah
yeah yeah younger yeah but it's
interesting
the tick tock world's weird right both
strange worlds you boys got into it it's
a very interesting world
there they're mega stars they're like
massive crazy
yes and how long does it last dave
another another 11 months
i don't know i mean i think the big ones
are here to stay like they might be
ray that the mellows yeah josh but the
vine stars beg to differ but yeah
yeah but even if you look like logan and
logan paul and jake paul they're viners
they're they're they're yeah that's fair
yeah i think that kid josh is really
smart
and i think people like him will figure
out a way to stick around
a great yeah dave are you into like the
logan paul floyd mayweather stuff
in the jake paul fights i am uh
all right so i thought jake paul would
lose
to nate robinson because i was of the
impression
i don't care what jake is like nate's a
professional basketball player
his athletic skill will overwhelm him
you want a dunk kind of the knockout
the way he did it it's like whoa what
just happened
and logan is so much bigger than
floyd and floyd is old now i don't know
the actual format of how it's going to
be like exhibition
but i'm curious and i'm curious to see i
will i thought
i thought jake would fight dylan danis
next that's obviously a much different
can of worms
but i would have been interested to i i
wasn't interested in the first fight
i'll be interested in both there next me
too me too
100 before we get you out of here dave
who how who do you
have win the super ball and you're a big
sports guy bills
the bills yeah josh allen's is [ __ ]
awesome stud
buffalo could use that bubble could use
all the help they can get yeah that will
be their bailout
if the bills win that's all they care
about hey didn't i hear in buffalo
because you know the bill
mafia listen i had a cappuccino with the
buffalo bills i was on the team for
eight days so i can talk like this okay
they i had to try out with them anyway
um the buffalo bills
they're the the bills mafia did didn't
they threaten
like the the governor cuomo like we have
to see the game
like so i think they're allowing in like
6500 people or something like that
and i'm sure the tickets are going to be
insane if i don't even know i assume
they're season ticket holders i have no
idea
why how that works but yes i heard they
are requiring a covid test
and they got an official covid test
partner and
you have to pay dollars to this specific
cova testing place
even though there's free ones in new
york so yeah they'll kind of know
there's no fraud with that
yeah yeah zero fraud dude if if i had to
get a cover test for
every single restaurant movie theater
sports [ __ ] i would get a test every
single place they asked me to get yeah
yeah just to go that's the world we live
in
well great job dave thanks for doing all
this for people hope maybe one day the
government will follow in your footsteps
you know hopefully that's the only way
they're gonna solve it or just open it
one of the
yeah well maybe we'll run into you in
miami when you move operations there my
man
all right talk to you guys later
[Music]